laticia liidé a des problèmes elle a des
dettes depuis la mort bien sûr de Johnny
qui n'ont pas fini voilà qui qui qui
sont pas finis elle en vient négocier un
répi avec le fisque car la maison de
main de la coquette ne trouve pas
d'acheteur je vous en ai déjà parlé je
vais vous en parler elle se retrouve
vraiment avec la corde au cou on vous
explique tout ici et Myriam Palomba
spécialiste des rasseras financière bien
sûr et sentimental sera avec nous dans
quelques minutes juste ici c'est
parti en 2017 la France perdait l'un des
plus grands monuments de la chanson
française Johnny halidday est mort il
avait 74 ans et en s'éteignant Johnny
hidday aurait laissé derrière lui de
nombreuses dettes et c'est vrai que
Johnny il avait énormément de dettes 34
millions des dettes auxquelles laticia
lid doit faire face alors qu'elle peine
à vendre la luxueuse villa de Marne la
coquette affichée à plus de 8 millions
d'euros sur les chiffres il y a eu
énormément de fantasmes la réalité c'est
qu'il y a du patrimoine peu de
trésorerie et beaucoup de dettes mais
aujourd'hui très endetté Leticia lid
viendrait d'obtenir un répit de la part
du Fiss Miriam Palomba nous explique
tout ce soir dans TPMP
[Applaudissements]
myiam Palomba alors latiti liidé euh
c'est pas la folie qu'est-ce qui se
passe c'est pas la folie alors comme
vous le savez peut-être elle doit à peu
près plus de 30 millions d'euros au FIS
qu'elle devait rembourser déjà la plus
de la moitié enfin 13 millions pardon
d'euros fisque d'ici la fin de l'été et
puis finalement elle a réussi à
échelonner ses échéances ou bah 30
millions échelonn c'est ça fait quand
même ça c'est combi par moi
c'est mais mais du coup elle avait elle
avait quand même réussi à négocier et ce
qui ce qui était important c'est qu'elle
devait négocier enfin elle devait payer
13 13 millions d'euros à la fin de l'été
elle a réussi à écheler comment tu
passes un été tranquille quand tu dois
payer 13 million d'euros à la fin de
l'été frère
t'achètte pas une glace he en rera total
tu prends un truc une glace non c'est
bon merci mer nonur de pas tu meur de
pas c'est vrai et donc finalement elle a
réussi à négocier avec le FIS et ils lui
ont donné jusqu'au 15 décembre pour
rembourser se dette ah ça va oh ais
trouver 13 barres en un mois ça va ouais
ça se trouve alors elle était plutôt
satisfaite et elle se disait que elle
allait pouvoir compter sur la vente de
la maison Mar de la coquette pour
rembourser cette fameuse dette je te dis
que c'est problématique voilà manque de
bol cette maison personne n'en veut
parce que bah les le style ne plaît pas
forcément aux acheteurs et puis en plus
elle attire tous les regards cette
maison les acheteurs qui peuvent se
payer une maison à 10,5 million d'euros
105 combien aujourd'i non 6 aujourd'hui
tu l' est non pour l'instant elle est
toujour affich moi je te dis qu' si a un
gars qui vient il dit je la prends à pas
baisser elle ne veut pas baisser à Cha
pour le moment elle veut pas proposition
même frère je te si normalement là en
mars elle avait même un acheteur qui dev
my je le connais le gars j c'est vrai je
la connais l'histoire c'est gars ilchè
toutes les mais finalement ça s pass de
je te jure que c'est vrai je le connais
le gars je connais le dossier par cœur
arrêtez vous av l'air bien renseigné
ouais oui je en tout cas quoi qu'il
arrive il faut qu'elle vende cette
maison une certaine somme puisqu'elle
doit rembourser 13 millions d'euros off
la maison je vous l'ai déjà dit la
maison le problème qu'il a mais non
c'est pas ça la maison même si tu
l'achètes à 6 bar tu as si bares de
travaux c'est très Moch à l'intérieur
question est-ce que est-ce que le Fiss
que peut pas s'emparer de la maison et
dire justement justement la maison de en
fait qu' a il a confisqueou la maison
devait être mise en en adjudication
c'est-à-dire qu'on la met aux enchères
ouis c'est ça on la met aux enchères on
force la vente le problème c'est que le
fils s'est rendu compte que s'il la
mettait aux enchères elle allait pas
rembourser la tte qu'elle doit le fils
qui con con prix de la maison ils ont
décidé de de mettre une pause là-dessus
et lui laisser le temps de trouver
l'argent pour rembourser cette dette de
13 millions au 15 décembre mais à mon
avis elle va encore réussir à négocier
parce que le fils qui est quand même
plutôt sympa avec elle hein d'une
manière générale le fisque il est Sympac
c'est
vrai ENIT qu me quand avec le fisque tu
fait pas le mec qui fait le et il trouve
toujours des échonnements à un moment
ils veulent il préfèrent avoir l'argent
que d'avoir un mec qui qui plante ou au
début elle était procédurière c'est
qu'elle a multiplié des recours quand
elle s'est trouvé face à cette dette
fiscal il y avait une SARL pour laquelle
elle est allé en justice et puis
finalement elle et le Fisk se sont rendu
compte ça ne marcherait pas comme ça
donc aujourd'hui le Fisk lui laisse
plusieurs années c'est vrai ils sont
extrêmement conciliant avec elle 15
décembre alors elle a vendu ça va renég
en elle a pas vendu la maison de
pacificque Pal vendu la mais alors elle
l'a vendu à Los Angeles à Los Angeles
voà elle l'a vendu 15 millions donc donc
ça ça ça ça ça a permis de elle a bien
vendu à Los Angeles oui mais en fait
elle s'est racheté une autre maison
derrière
doncelle elle a pu rembourser si sielle
si elle achète enfin si elle la maison
15 millions alors qu'elle en doit 13
pourquoi elle garde pas juste les deux
voilà puis
demand voilà elle a pas voulu comme le
fils qui est sympa avec elle elle a pas
non plus lacord de coup et puis il faut
savoir que quand même elle continue à
recevoir des royalties assez
conséquentes de la de la part de des des
droits d'auteur de Johnny ALID donc
qu'est-ce johnnyid donc elle touche à
peu près en moyenne 600000 € par an et
et du coup bah elle voilà elle va
essayer de rembourser petit à elle
profite un peu de cette du CP pas la V
pas la vill là si alors mais elle les
pas mise en
venteou elle les loue et chaque semaine
ça 30000
€ BV
lou par semaine 30000 € par semaine les
maisarent ah ouais elle est lou mais
c'est ça qui est pas logique tu peux pas
entendre que il y a un accord qui est
fait avec le fils pour dire vous ne
payez pas tout de suite ouais mais les
Français quand tu quand tu dois des
impôts tu les PASC tes impôts on te dit
pas tu vas négocier en disant quoi si tu
as l'argent ils vont il vont dire si tu
as
l'argent reste 2 millions elle a une
autre maison à saintm les mecs arrête tu
crois que son rythme vie son rythme de
vie il il est comment son rythme de vie
attendss tu veux parler de son rythme de
vie
r son rythme de vie son
rymee vas-y vasy parce les staffettes
qui on en double
fil mais par rapport au moyen français
c'est sûr qu'elle a un niveau de vie
très élevé
son rythme de
vie il est très rapide il est très
rapide mais
mtenant avant elle voyage en jet privé
maintenant elle voyage en business voilà
et puis elle a encore de ses
filles maiset privé
avant respect quand même je peux te dire
que jet privé privé en jet en jet privé
c'est 150000
je dis 150000 € ah bah je vous le dis je
vous le dis bah il a annoncé quelque
chose
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non
e non non non mais non mais je suis
jamais à Saint-Bart genre Paris non mais
Paris Saint-Bart en J privé Paris
Saint-Bart Saint-Bart retour et ça parce
que sinon tu restes là-bas mais c'est
c'est 100 150000 € ou pour combien de
personnes pour combien de personnes B
après fa voir ça dépend ce que tu prends
si tu prends un jet es avec tes amis tu
prends jet 10 personnes enfin
personnes qui font ça maintenant il pay
voilà c'est sûr qu'elle joue avec le
système parce qu'en plus il para qu' on
me dit moi qu'elle est mine de rien elle
a beaucoup d'argent elle a vendu 18 bar
il para la maison de 18 oui oui et puis
surtout le truc c'est qu'elle a un trust
qui est assez opaque et qui lui rapporte
de
l'argent ben c'est un montage financier
qui est situé aux États-Unis dont on
sait
pas elle a de Trust aux États-Unis donc
on n pas trop de regard dessus et du
coup bah forcément il y a de l'AR qui VI
ça elle a pas à payer les impôts en
France avec son trust au ét la
Maisonelle vaut 25
bûches donc donc elle TR aux impôts là
ça y est c'est frais et ça ça se
vendrait pour le coup écoute elle a
décidé pour l'instant de pas la mettre
en vente mais de de la louer chaque
semain al on me confirme que pour le jet
c'est le bon prix he
150000 mec qui te l'a dit ça hein c'est
le mec qui te l' dit c'est comm ça que
tu le sais 150 je sais pas c'est un mec
qui ah oui c'est un mec qui me l'a dit
comptable je suis jamais
la compable mais elle a pas non plus
très envie de vendre cette maison parce
que c'est làbas johnny c'est vraiment la
maison de
johnnyah oui mais bon si elle peut nég
elle peut négocier avec le fils et s'en
sortir comme ça pourquoi pas aussi
parfois il a pas envie de mettre deux
fois le
même il est obligé qu'est tu veux je te
le dis quoi et comme elle revient fin
novembre là elle est obligé de les
dégage un peu donc c'est pour ça aussi
qu'on en parle elle va essayer de
trouver un peu d'argent mais c'est vrai
qu'ils sont extrêmement cléments c'est
aussi parce que c'est la dette fiscale
de Johnny donc le fils qui est très mais
mais évidemment moi je suis allé moi
franchement j'avais des dettes parce que
j'étais tu es pas tu es pas là AR
pas moi aussi j'ai des detts je
rembourse 50 balles au
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
boulanger
j'avais des det non j'avais des dettes
fiscales et ils ont été vachement
cléments j'avais des dettes de mon de
mon ex-mi je devais de l'argent et je
suis allé voir le le le fisque et ils
m'ont fait un échelonnement de la même
manière et effectivement comme tu le dis
je ne suis pas les tu prenais pas 18
millions ils t'ont fait un échéancier
par rapport à ton rythme de vie tu t'
ramené des fiches de P je gagne ça je
vous dois ça comment on fait mais là 18
millions j'ai gagné 18 millions mais je
vous paye pas je rachète une maison j'en
relou une autre les pas 18
mil ils sont dans un trust voilà c'est
comme faire ça c'està direire c'est
auaque ben c'est-à-dire qu'on peut pas
le fils ne peut pas aller chercher cet
argent comme ça dans ce truc là par que
c'est des montages
financiers pas aller l' fis bah c'est
compliqué c'est très compliqué mais
c'est souvent comme ça mais même sans
s'appeler ltitiidé quand vous décidez de
monter une boîte à l'étranger et cetera
et que vous devez de l'argent en France
pour aller chercher l'argent dans dans
ces comptes là c'est très compliqué
ouais ça a été tout l'objet du litige au
moment de du décès de de Johnny puisque
justement il y avait cette histoire de
Trust dont on savait pas vraiment ce
qu'il y avait à l'INT donc les lois sont
pas les mêmes pour tout le monde bah
c'est au
éatsis T si tu dois de l'argent en
France Jean-Michel si tu dois de
l'argent en France et tu veux pas payer
à un moment donné
payerelle ve pay à par tu ve P fois tu
veux payer il t'arrange oui mais vrai
qu'il pourit pour récupérer une partie
de la dette ils auraient très bien pu
mettre mal la coquette en vente quoi
qu'il arrive elle rembourse une certaine
partie et du coup même si c'est aux
enchères et que ça rapporte pas autant
en tout cas ils auraient pu la mettre en
vente et récupérer une partie de
l'argent ce qu'ils ne font pas pourquoi
elle rapatrie pas l'argent du trust en
France c'est au Pakistan est que elle
veut garder non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'estelle
ça c'est opaque
opaque ça veut dire que il peut il peut
le sortir que vers
avril dis-moi alors on m parlé on va
faire le point sur les biens de latia
rien cont il y a la vente de la maison
donc Pacifique palissade en 2021 les
gars vous
faites bien mais attendez au moins qu'on
finisse l'émission qu elle a permis
d'éponger un peu la dette mais pas assz
elle aurait été vendue donc 14 millions
de dollars moi on me dit 18 moi j'ai 15
moi on me dit
16ose
ce Mo on me dit 18 je pense que c'est
plutôt 15 mais bon c'est pas moi je te
dis 16 va faire aucun pas l'un vers
l'autre c'est vous qui l'avez racheté
non pas du tout et je sais même pas où
c'est Pacific palissade Conz la
palissade à stalingrade mais euh la
villa de Marne la coquette 900 m² donc
ça elle a été saisie non non elle est
pas saisie justement justement elle a
été exésie à titre confiscatoire
conservatoire oui oui mais justement il
devait la mettre en adjudication et ils
on ils ont décidé de pas le faire donc
c'est c'est encore un quelque chose
assez sympathique ils en voulit 15
bûches
tout début quand elle l'a mis sur le
marché ne dis pas non plus n'imp toi
comment tu peux
savoir elle était à 15 bûches 15 après
elle a été à à 10 bûches oua puis 8 45
bûches oua c'est Faou et là je vous le
dis 6 à 4 et demi elle part
4 sera embêtant qu'elle parte à 4 ce
sera embêtant qu'elle parte à 4 et demi
parce que c'est le montant pour le
montant ils l'ont acheté 4 million et
demi donc il aurait pasouri tu g pas
d'argent tu as vuas vu tu as vu l'état
de l'immobilier tu imagines tu imagines
les travaux qu'il a faire làdedans je
t'explique à 900 m² je t'explique tu
fais allez 1000 € du mtre plus tu gentil
je suis gentil allez 2000 € du MRE et
ben je t'explique bah fais ton calcul
che pas à 4 et dem pas à 4 tu connaisob
expquer pouras vendu un appart jours tu
te l'
racontes il était tout fier il est venu
dans mon il m'a dit app c'est
l'intérieur de la maison ça franchement
ça va c'est pas si regarde
regardeattendais un tr c'est pas c'est
pas un
truc je dis qu' y a plein de
travauxitéit je vous expliquer pouri je
vais vous expliquer pour on
Stan justement le fisque a eu peur de la
vente aux enchères ça c'est ça ça c'est
ah j'adore mais ça rien à voir avec un
magasin de choc quand ils ont voulu
vendre aux enchères d'accord le fisque
avait déjà prospecté et ils ont eu peur
que l'acheteur maximal aille à 4 et demi
donc du coup ils se sont dit c'est pas
possible c'est le le seul bien pour
lequel ils ont une prise sur laticia
s'il le brade à 4 et demi le fils
français est foutu tu brades pas tu mets
un prix de réserve s'il atteint pas le
prix de réserve juste mais non il y
avait qu ils avaient 4 et demi donc du
coup ils se sont dit on arrête ça et on
tente de vendre à 8 Cyril je vous assure
que c'est je te dis si vend à 8 bah je
te le dis je m'appelle pas Nouna je te
le dis impossible de la vendre à 8 et
impossible tu crois vraiment qu'on va
c'est une villa qui va coûter 14 barres
à Marne la coquette frère c'est bon là B
mais toi si tu veux non mais c'est
vraiur de leç là mais non mais pas 14
mais pas 4 et demi on s'embrouille sur
la maison de
Joh la maison de Johnny elle part à 4 et
demi en ce moment l'immobilier est au
plus bas mais qu'est-ce que tu crois il
y a pas une transaction qui se fait
c'est vrai tu vois bien qu'il y a pas
une transaction immobilière qui bah
ouais tu crois vraiment qu'il y a un
gars il va arriver il va dire je vais
mettre 10 barres dans la maison mais tu
me le montes moi je vais m'en occuper
t'inquiète pas un pigeon comme ça je
vais m'en occuper et ben tu vas voir je
vais lui en vendre des trucs moi je en
trouver des maisons à alors le juste
prix ce serait quoi le le vrai bon juste
c'est 4 4 et 4 45 vous étiez assis tout
à l'heure bah j'ai d bah oui mais on
a j'ai dit ça il était 20h15 20 minutes
dis hein dire que l'immobilier ça ça
blanche alors a dites-moi euh elle a
toujours la ville à l mais c'est quoi
cette vill là qu'elle acheté pour vivre
avec Jalil et ben c'est une vill là
qu'elle a acheté aussi à Los Angeles
dans acheté deux villas une une à Los
Angeles non elle en a vendu une à Los
Angeles 15 millions elle en a racheté
voilàcomis
5 toujours à Angeles elle pouvit pas
acheter un peu moins cher pour c'est
vrai mais si elle peut toujours
qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te dise
elle peut toujours acheter moins cher
mais bon elle a des elle a des coups de
l tu
vois justement si le F lui mettait plus
la pression si peut-être le fils lui
mettait un peu plus la pression éta un
peu moins gentil peut-être
qu'elle la pression vous êtes méchant
oui mé
normal quand tu es endetté c'est normal
que un moment quand on voit que tu as un
rythme de vie complètement dingue et
tout il y a une s de
[Rires]
parch
artificielle bon qu'ils ont été moins
indulg avec d'autres personnalités ou
toujours
avecal est
avec un jeune businessman qui s'appelle
al qu'elle a rencontré à oui ah ouais
oui dans un club de plongée cl ah ouais
c'est vrai ils ont fait de la plongée
ensemble et alors là ils ont pas
concrétisé à ce momentl ils ont
attenduuse-moi tu étais sous
l'
dis il ont pas
concrétisé c'est vrai parce qu'à ce
momentl elle avait pas trop envieess de
la draguer et cetera après ils ont
continué à se par par sur les réseaux
sociaux et elle est venue à Paris au
mois d'octobre et là ils ont passé ils
ont d'abord dîné dans un dans un
restaurant dans l' 11e arrondissement et
puis ils ont passé la nuit c'est les
photos de voici on l' voit du coup il il
a les boules non ah bah il a grave les
boules mais JAL il était pas il était
pas au niveau et puis il était très
jroable je veux dire au niveau
financier un énorme réalisateur pas au
niveau financier je vous parle de
Leticia il
é je veux que tu
développes dans un instant tu as
développé j'aime pas ça ah oui
[Applaudissements]
oui